because you had a good time in england
but tell the people
yeah do you want to do that here or
should we save that for the patreon no
let's just do it cause
make no mistake if the people who booked
me here
then so be it i'm spinning the wheel
so here's the truth to the situation if
you if you're if you're owner of that
club
and you know i sent an email and
somebody died in a family emergency not
if it's true
it's just what it is can i get to just
what it is with different languages
please can you post to the patreon
remember do we pay isis too much
yeah the truth of this the truth of the
situation is this
i i had shows in london from the at the
soho theater yeah monday and tuesday by
the way thank you so many hyena fans
came out you guys know who you are thank
you for
um it's so amazing to me and giannis
that we have international um
fans so thank you guys so much for
coming out to the shows in london and we
will come back as the history hyenas and
do the soho theater next year i promise
you that did you
call it well first tell us what you did
and then i want to know what your cocoa
uh situation was i told you i coco girl
who i'm not sure if it was
if it was a guy or a girl the lights
were off and she she wouldn't take her
pants off and she would only keep the
lights on but i was spinning the wheel
and i was about
uh four amp still lights in so i was
[ __ ] hammered again i like that
you're watching you wait while you do
this
yeah i'm trying to stay light beers yeah
so um
monday tuesday soho theater was great
then thursday uh wednesday
i took the train i had shows at the
stand new castle and i took
um the train up there um it's about a
three and a half hour train ride up into
northern england where
uh you know it's just a different place
like northern england it was nice
it was great the people were great but
it's just you're really far away
from london and then i felt really far
away from new york city you're really
far away from the baby and you're really
far away from yanni at that point yeah
i'm really you need to be close to
either yani or the baby
or patty flat balls paddy five balls and
and and i was really really far away um
my phone didn't work unless i had wi-fi
in the hotel which was
[ __ ] uh no it wasn't a piece of [ __ ] it
was it was actually a beautiful hotel
but it's a small thing
small little little itty bitty hotel and
um james debo
little debo was supposed to come out and
meet me because he works for jetblue he
does the bags but he tells girls he's a
pilot but he does the bags
um he was supposed to come he was
supposed to come meet me
uh when uh thursday morning so i was
only supposed to have one
night alone in newcastle so
he would you would have just sucked it
up for you you got a ball just no
no no i did wednesday night i you know i
did what i always do i slept
in the hotel bed with all the uh with
all the lights on yeah and the tv on
yeah
i have the water running so i have a
sound i had the water running in the
bathroom yeah so there's always a sound
to something
um and then i i put on uh music and i
fell asleep
and i woke up and i woke up i popped out
of bed every two hours yeah with my
heart racing and then once the sign this
with your fingers yeah
my fingers and then once and then once
the sun and then once the sun came up
i knew i was good to go but
unfortunately when the sun came up i
there was a text from debo saying
listen you know i just thought i just
thought that i could go to any airline
and say that i work
here at jfk for jetblue and they would
let me on a flight but that's not how it
works
he said so i couldn't get standby in any
flight so unfortunately i can't come he
said because jetblue doesn't go
he goes jetblue is only going to start
flying to london in 2020 you think he'll
still be there
and i was like i swear and i was like
nah man
so then i started to then the idea
started to creep in started to slowly
creep in that i should
probably leave yeah so yeah i don't know
where that idea came from but it came
from
a place that look i understand you were
across the atlantic ocean yeah and you
didn't feel safe
i didn't feel safe you don't feel
protected by jesus because jesus put the
atlantic ocean there to keep us safe
to keep us safe jesus put the atlantic
ocean between america
and and its enemies there for a reason
and also i was i was outside of the
borders of the wall so i can't be
protected by the wall if i'm over it
yeah so it's white walkers everywhere
there's white walkers everywhere and
they really don't like americans
over there yeah um and one of the comics
was mouthing off about america and i was
like
you're going about to lose your head
yeah you're about to lose your [ __ ]
see within range
i'm going to stuff a couple of american
hot dogs in there one of them is going
to be my dick
yeah so you just yeah so treat the ufo
like a speed bag i'll treat you you'll
be like a speed bag i don't care
yeah so why and say in it while you're
doing it in it
so when so so that was thursday i
started to creep the idea and then i was
going for a run
and then i'm sure my mind created it
wait is that before or
after you told the ritz carlton staff
that you were a baseball player okay so
monday and tuesday what happened real
quick just backtrack and i stayed at the
ritz carlton in london for about a
thousand a night
um and uh so you were basically losing
money on this i'm just losing money hand
over fist but you were spinning the
wheel i was just
[ __ ]
so i got into the ritz carlton and they
invented class and fashion in london and
the ritz carlton is like the original
ritz is is
london so so everybody's in suits you
know a thousand dollar suits ted baker
suits whatever it may be hugo ball shout
out adolf
um so all of them all of them were in
suits and i came in
lululemon sweats an overthrow boxing
sweatshirt and a bat
and uh and a yogurt from pretty mange
air and
you were you were in a walking american
flag i was a walking american flag so i
came in
and they couldn't believe that i was a
guest there like the guy kept checking
me in he was like
he gave first of all i gave him my
license he's like oh we can't find your
name
yeah and i was like no it's there i
booked and then i pulled up the reserve
confirmation and then he put it in
and goes it's not popping up i was like
it's right here yeah and then he finally
the third time and he's like oh
here it is like he was trying to on
purpose be like
get out and i could see security kind of
looking at me
and kind of just being in the area yeah
because they want you out they wanted me
out
and then he was like what brings you
into town and i was like i'm on the
yankees why i played for the new york
games
and he was like oh for the baseball game
that's coming this weekend i was like
yeah i'm a
i'm a relief pitcher yeah and uh he was
like okay
right here and then they gave me to the
room they gave me the room
and then uh and then yesterday i ordered
room service i spent i would say i spent
about uh
about three thousand dollars in two days
yeah spin the wheel i spun the wheel and
three thousand pounds so we're looking
about 4 500 in america yeah welcome to a
new game show called chrissy d
spins the wheel is he going to win money
lose money get gonorrhea we don't know
i don't know so i spun the wheel and
that was monday night um at the ritz
carlton then tuesday and i got the
[ __ ] from the he she or i don't know
what it was
you were spinning the wheel cause i was
spinning the way i was having a good
time was it a good blowy it was uh it
was a little toothy it was a little
toothpaste
okay it's probably a girl there because
make a mistake if it was a guy they
probably know how to do it better well
they had pretty big hands too
yeah okay so um yeah
so so do that i do that and then um
was there any hair on the knuckles no
but it was dark in there
no but i thought was there an adam's
apple i thought i felt testicles
you thought so she wouldn't take her
pants off
where'd you move thank you where'd you
meet her at the show
okay she's at the show where she think
fannica's uh
i hope what is wrong with you guys i
mean you didn't tell me she was a fan
before we started talking about this
do we need to tackle this all out it's
what it is
do we need a cackle here i'm not
mentioning any names no i know but we're
calling her maybe a guy
yeah but we're joking yeah we're doing a
character piece
we're doing a character last one
yeah yeah yeah so um yeah so anyway so
in newcastle
plus they got a different legal system a
different legal assistant yeah
um um thursday so thursday i go out for
a jog in newcastle which is beautiful by
the way i went on a nice tour
and i saw the ancient city of durham
which was good i hired a local tour
guide and then i told them and then i
took a picture of him and i said it's
for my podcast and then i just told my
fans i met him on grindr yeah it's just
what it is
it's just what happens if he and he said
he was going to follow me on instagram
so now he knows
yeah follow us on instagram because you
posted it to at history hyenas at
history
and also patreon.com bay ridge boys so
thursday
what happens is is um so thursday what
happens
is is um i go out for a jog and i start
to feel like really
kind of sharp pains in my lower stomach
and i know it was probably nothing yeah
but i convinced myself stomach cancer
well no that my appendix was about to
burst and i needed to get home to
freedom yeah i needed to get within the
wall so i have
the best healthcare in this [ __ ]
planet even though it ain't free yeah
so you wanted an eastern hemi or a south
asian doctor immediately
immediately so what i do i start to have
the idea of
you know what i gotta leave so we're
having a conversation all the comics are
talking thursday night at the show about
plans that we're gonna have friday plans
we're gonna have saturday and i'm like
yeah i can't wait i'm just gonna be
great i'm gonna go we're gonna meet for
coffee
i'm going to go saturday we're supposed
to go to some beach towns like i never
seen the atlantic ocean
from the english side i'm excited and
then
i went back to my room they were like oh
we're going to hang out i was like you
know what i'm going to just turn in
because we got a big day tomorrow we're
going to it's going to be exciting
and then i go into my room now wait a
second this whole time you know that
you're just lying to them because you're
not going to show up yeah because
i've already used a train ticket back to
london
so it's already been booked and it's on
my phone so you're just
you're you're you've done that and the
rest of it you're just winging it you're
like i'm gonna
i'm gonna cross the bridges as they come
and figure out how i'm gonna do damage
control yeah yeah and i'm just i'm just
lying
i'm lying yeah so and you're admitting
it and this is why you're chrissy
there's just the lights broke and we
need the city to come fix it yeah
so this is an intersection it needs a
red light it needs a red light i can't
have one
so so what happens is is i just say to
myself
all right i'm going to leave so it's
about 12 o'clock my train back to
uh london is at 6 a.m so i just
stayed awake i literally sat i was fully
dressed sitting at the edge of my bed
watching friends reruns on their local
um tv channel itv4
and i waited till it was 5 50 and i was
just up
watching tv because i was so excited to
come home and then i started walking to
the train station got on the train at
605
got into london uh saint pancras
uh i'm sorry king's cross station at 9
30. um
and then i just got in a cab in 150 uber
i just got 150 uber because i should
have taken the train but i just wanted
to [ __ ] get to
the airport so and it was an hour and a
half of traffic so i got to the airport
and i didn't have a flight and i just
walked up to the desk at virgin atlantic
i said look i got a business class
ticket
thank you mountain dew i said i want to
get on the next flight back to jfk i
don't care if i have to sit coach middle
seat
just get me back there and then they
said well you're in luck
because there's a business class um
ticket available for the 12 o'clock
flight so i said i'll take it so i gotta
i get on the flight
um and then i realize we're in the
middle of the atlantic ocean i realized
i forgot to email
the club and i forgot to text the comic
that i wasn't gonna make
any of the plans that i said so i sent
it i sent a i sent an email and a text
from the
middle of the atlantic ocean telling the
club i had a family emergency that
somebody died
and telling the comic friend that um i
also had a family emergency and it was a
pleasure to meet them and
and i and i really am upset that i had
to leave because i was looking forward
to the next two days
and uh this was just yankees red sox
tickets and i spent 250 pounds of ticket
on that i just
left so i lost about 5 000 pounds
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]